they're being laid to rest victims of
lebanon's worst migrant boat tragedy in
years
many of those who died were Palestinian
refugees
they'd been here for decades but lived
with little or no rights at all their
situation was made worse by lebanon's
economic collapse that began three years
ago
we lost 30 people from Camp the
Palestinian leadership should shoulder
responsibility and guarantee good living
conditions so we can live in dignity or
open the border so we can go back to
Palestine
bodies that have been identified are
being brought back to Lebanon but that
takes time some have started to
decompose the boat set sail on Tuesday
but sank off the coast of neighboring
Syria two days later
families are desperate for any news they
didn't promise us anything they said we
should go identify the bodies first as
we have no idea if they're still alive
or dead we still don't know anything in
recent years the North Lebanon Coast has
become a migrant route to Europe an
increasing number of Lebanese have
joined Palestinian and Syrian refugees
attempting to make the dangerous Journey
we have seen the number of people
attempting to depart in the number of
boats departing doubled from 21 to 20
compared to 20 and that number tripled
if you compare it from January to
September 2022. that shows how desperate
these people are in order to protect
their families and to provide for their
families it's believed that up to 150
people could have been on board the
overcrowded boat nearly 50 of the bodies
found are reported to have been of
children
the Lebanese Army says it Arrested a man
who's confessed to being behind the
attempt to smuggle the boat to Europe it
wasn't the first arrest of its kind
neither was the tragedy in April a
migrant boat sank some six kilometers
off the coast of Lebanon and dozens of
people were never found
few expected dangers and the security
Crackdown in Lebanon to stop The Exodus
as long as living conditions worsened a
few days before the boat sank off the
Syrian Coast migrants on board another
vessel that left Lebanon Shores were
rescued by Turkish coast guards but not
before six of them had died including
two babies
Beirut